- Thanks everyone for joining.
My name is Andrew Sun, from Nvidia.
I help lead our global
business development
for the retail and commerce industries.
Welcome to this session.
It's really great to see
such a full room after lunch.
And also, it says a lot
to be at a conference
like AWS re:Invent,
where there's just so many announcements
about the latest data, compute, models.
And at the same time,
so many of you coming
to join us to talk
about something that is,
frankly as human as it
gets, conversations.
Voice AI is really evolving quickly.
It's no longer just a simple command.
Today, it's rich, it understands
the context of a dialogue.
It can understand your
intent, your emotion,
domain specific language.
And all of this is happening in real time.
A lot of this breakthrough
is happening because of infrastructure
with the cloud and AWS,
with accelerated computing and GPUs,
as well as foundation models.
And all of this is becoming
so much more tangible
for every consumer and every enterprise.
Such that the everyday tasks that we do,
whether that's customer support,
whether that's ordering your food,
whether that's transcribing
a medical note,
this is all being rapidly
transformed with voice.
I'm excited about our panel today,
because we're gonna explore
where voice AI is today
in the market.
What does it really take
to run a voice AI workload,
not just in a pilot,
but actually scale that into production?
And you're gonna be hearing stories
from the people that are
building these products.
And they're building them at scale.
They're tackling all the hard problems.
Latency, cost, privacy, safety,
but ultimately trust of their customers
and of their employees.
So with that, thank you all for coming.
And let's get started.
I'd love to invite my panelists
to please introduce themselves.
- Cool.
Hi everyone.
So, my name is Shawn,
co-founder and CTO of PolyAI.
So, PolyAI is based in London.
We do voice agent for
enterprise contact centers.
We work with some of the
largest enterprise in the world,
and including utility
companies, financial services,
and lots of hospitality, and
restaurants and hotels as well.
So yeah, well glad to be here,
and love to share more with everyone here.
- Alright, so I'm Cameron Davies.
So, I'm the chief data
officer for Yum! Brands.
So for those of you who
don't know Yum! Brands,
we're the world's largest
restaurant company.
So, you've probably heard of
Pizza Hut, Taco Bell, KFC,
or hopefully have a burger
if you're on the west coast.
With about 65,000 units worldwide.
So, we're using voice
in a number of places
across the enterprise.
We're happy to talk about
it in a few minutes.
- [Andrew] I think we got
the most loyal customers
in a developer conference.
At least Taco Bell, certainly more.
(Cameron chuckles)
- I'm Prem.
I'm a machine learning engineer
and founding engineer of Heidi Health.
Heidi is an AI care partner.
We use voice-based, we do
voice-based clinical documentation
and workflow automation for clinicians.
So, clinicians can spend
less time taking notes,
and more time on the patients.
We based outta Melbourne, Australia.
And we launched this product
a couple of years ago.
And we scaled to supporting
thousands of uses worldwide.
I'm really looking forward to chat,
and good to meet all of you.
- Excellent.
Well, thanks for joining us today.
We're so excited to have
this diverse point of view
here on this panel for everyone.
Let's jump right in.
I think in so many times when we're going
through a technology paradigm shift,
there's always sort of a
sprinkling of a thousand seeds
to kind of see what blooms.
But ultimately what we're really
here for is solving real customer
problems and pain points.
So, let's jump right in.
Could each of you share
a real world example
of where voice AI is transforming
a core business process
from your vantage point?
- Yeah, we deploy a lot of
voice agent for different,
of different verticals
and many of our customers,
so it's kind of quite hard for me
to actually pick one specific case.
I will pick one anyway.
So, because we just had
a Black Friday, right?
So we actually work with
one of our retail customers
here in the US.
We started with launching a
voice agent with them first,
because our primary
drive is always driving
for the voice first.
And that's kind of our
product for the focus
since the company was funded.
The customer use already work
with chat vendors as well.
So they do online chat,
which is actually a very common thing,
that Black Friday they
got a lot of traffic.
They also got a lot of search
traffic during Black Friday.
It's about three X of their normal volume
during that week.
And typically, what they have to do
is that they need to staff three X
of the existing contact center people
in order to take and
digest loads of volumes.
But the problem of that is
that they have to staff,
started hiring a couple months ago.
And then it's always a temporary job,
because after Black Friday
they're going to scale back the operation.
So the training, the hiring,
and afterwards letting people go,
it's a very expensive process overall.
They started with chat, and
then they wanted to do voice.
But voice is hard,
so they partner with us
to launch the voice agent.
And once we launched the voice agent,
you would thought that
people, the business,
we started to let people go
and they reduce workforce.
The reality is that they just don't have
to handle these kind of seasonalities.
They keep their workforce around,
because there are so many things to do
in the contact center anyway.
If they are not picking on the call,
they can totally do something else.
So, I think we always thought
that AI would take people's job away.
It's probably going to be true.
We talk a little bit already.
But what we are seeing now with
a lot of our customer base,
it just smooths that main curve,
and make it a lot easier for
them to manage operationally.
This last week we took over
their chat deployments as well.
So now, we are the only
channel vendor for them.
So, the customer can actually get in touch
with the B2B business online
chat, order something,
and then funding, and then
we would know who they are
and when they place the order.
So, I think that to me is a very cool
and interesting case study there.
- That's a great one.
And I feel like we've heard that in,
at least in the retail industry a lot,
in the sense that the expectation
versus what actually happens
is that the cognitive load
on these very retail demanding,
or business operations where it's,
the operations are so
intense and they spike,
no one in that industry
ever feels like they have
enough hours in the day
just to do their job.
And so, you actually
shift that cognitive load.
And a lot of the times we're
hearing customers being able
to actually serve customers, right?
And focus on the actual
connection with their end user.
Cam, what are you seeing in your business?
- Yeah, I think our most
impactful is the one we've been
the most vocal about and most public with.
We're looking at voice
AI right now in two ways.
Which one is in the drive through,
and the other is in call centers.
And we've done another
of other applications
where we haven't really
talked about publicly.
Those are the two big ones.
In the drive through, we are
live with a voice solution
in over 600 Taco Bells sitting here today.
Running live, it's been
a journey of learning.
What we found is really interesting.
We talk about cutting labor,
that really wasn't, isn't
our key premise off of it.
It goes back to what
you, you use the term,
we use that term, which
is the cognitive load.
Which is if you've ever,
I don't know anybody work fast food
ever in their teenage career.
A couple of people.
If you've ever, you want stress,
put on a headset, go
sit at a cash register
at a busy Taco Bell that's running,
let's call it four or 5 million AUVs,
which is a pretty big
good size for a Taco Bell.
And during a lunch rush.
And try to take an order, cash
out an order, fill a drink,
grab a bag, make sure it's
right, get it to a customer.
They're all really friendly and happy,
and everybody's rational, right?
(Andrew laughs)
It's tough, right?
It is tough,
and it takes a set of mental
toughness to go do it.
So, our thoughts are if you do this,
what we can do is we can
take that cognitive load off,
we can make it easier
for these team members
to do their jobs.
And in our experiment so
far, I call it an experiment.
We're scaled at 600 stores.
Now, that's 600 outta
60,000 across the globe.
But still.
What we're finding is really
interesting, which is,
if you get it right, it
can do the job pretty well.
And in some of our best
stores it can be successful
somewhere from 70 to 80% of the time.
That it just takes the
order from start to finish.
And so, it can do, and
it's just getting better.
We're finding that consumers
are getting more used
to dealing with it as it's getting better.
In the restaurant, we see a
couple of interesting things
on a direct value perspective.
Like it never forgets to upsell,
it never forgets to ask about Roundup.
And so, you see some financial advantages
there for your franchisees.
And then for the team members,
what we see in restaurants
that use it and leave it on,
we see dramatic decreases in turnover.
Which is, our keyest KPI to say,
are we making it better to do this job?
- Right.
- And then if you're a franchisee
and you understand what it takes to,
how much it takes to go hire
a new person and train them,
that's a pretty big
financial incentive as well.
- That's great.
- For Heidi, I feel like voice AI
is the core of how we operate.
You must of all noticed
that when you go see a GP
in a clinic, you walk in.
And then you see your GP
sitting in front of a computer,
ready to take notes.
You sit on your bed,
the GP is asking like,
"Hey how's your..."
Let's just say you have a chest pain.
The GP is like, "Hey,
how's your chest pain?
How do you rate the pain?"
And every now and then,
the GP shifts between
you and the computer,
just taking notes,
making sure that they're
getting everything
that you said into the computer.
And that just sort of makes
you feel like GPS focus
more on the computer than on you.
And there's a chance that
the GPs could be missing out
on real details of what you're saying.
And what Heidi does is,
Heidi uses voice AI to
take automate all of that.
So, the GPs gets full time spent on you.
You just have this ambiance
scribe in the background,
just listen on the conversation.
Just make sure that it picks up
on everything that you're saying
so the doctors put the
full attention on you.
And also the, I feel like
with what Heidi does is,
the benefit is twofold.
One is that make sure that GPs get
to spend more time on you,
they hear what you're saying,
making sure that they don't miss out
on any information that you say,
so that everything's accurate
and you don't have to really think
about them losing on anything.
And the second thing is,
GPs don't have to spend a lot of time
after their usual
operating hours making sure
that they get all the admin
work and everything done.
So, it's sort of like it
takes a lot of cognitive load
away from the GPs,
and also make sure that
GPs free up their time
to spend more time with the patients.
- Prem, you used a really
interesting word there
about ambient, right?
Like that it's constantly there.
Talk to us more about
kind of what you're seeing
there in terms of user
adoption and engagement.
- Yeah, so sometimes when we
feel more about technology
is that it kind of hinders
the way we do our everyday things.
You have a phone, you have a laptop,
you also have to spend a lot
of time interacting with it.
You're typing things into it,
you have to take your time away
from your normal activities to do things.
But with voice AI,
you can make the technology
not feel that pervasive.
It's more like a thing
that's in the background,
listening or doing
whatever you want to do.
It's like a way for you to
interact with the platform
without actually having
to spend a lot of time
away from your day to day activities.
Like for Scribe,
it's just something that's
listening in the background,
making sure that it takes a
lot of the manual labor away.
And also, it captures the conversation
and makes it into a structured way
when you connect to an LLM as well.
So, it's like a really good
way for you to interact
with the system
than actually having
take too much time away.
- Yeah, thanks for that.
I think in many ways that's
sort of the future, right?
Is this technology only gets
more personal, more fast,
more relevant for the user,
that ambiance and how you
interact with it becomes
so conversational.
It's like we all have an
assistant with us at all times.
Which then kind of begs the question of,
how do you scale this technology, right?
If everyone starts to form the new habit,
and it really starts to adopt and scale,
what are some of those
technical considerations
that really need to come to
mind if you are building this
or partnering this for your enterprise?
So, let's talk about the technology side.
Shawn, maybe you can
start us off here with,
what are you seeing as the
hardest technical challenge
when it comes to scaling
a voice AI solution
from a pilot into a production?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I think for after ChatGPT launched,
I think the world becomes
a very different place.
Because PolyAI existed before that time.
I think the LM actually make
building of these agents
a lot faster and easier.
However, you would see that once you try
to get it to production, you
run into a lot of challenges.
And I think, I usually like to say is,
this technology get you to
70, 80 percent really fast.
Basically a couple of hours
of work you will be there.
And you thought that you have
already reached that level
of productioness.
And once you get into production,
you realize there are so
many different problems.
The hallucinations,
the instruction for the
following capabilities.
These are all getting better as well.
But when we bring in voice,
there's an additional layer of complexity.
Is about the speech recognition errors.
Is that if the TT is sound robotic,
a user will not be engaging.
And you started to solve
the whole business problem.
I think the technical
problem is one layer,
but then there's another
layer on top of it
is the adoption problem.
Is like, hey adoption in my thinking
is that you need three personas
to actually buy into this.
One is the enterprise, the
B2B business you sell to,
they need to feel that they're getting ROI
from the solution, right?
So, that ROI calculation
is very important.
The second layer is the consumers.
Eventually the voice agent
is going to talk to your customer.
Does the customer like to
talk to the voice agent?
Unfortunately in this
country the answer is no,
because you have try out a lot of these,
like an automatic phone systems,
which is still predominantly the majority
of the install base,
they are not very good.
And so therefore, that when human realize,
when people realize
this is actually an AI,
they immediately wanted to
hang up on the phone call.
That's like working in contact center,
one of the major issues we are seeing.
So, the user B2B appearance
of the first turn
is very important.
You gotta understand very accurately.
You're gonna say in a very
crispy way that people feel like,
oh this agent actually
sound very different
from the previous ones I interact with.
So that is a tricky one.
I think the third one about scaling
is about procurement adoption.
Like now you heard AI industry,
a lot of people doing
forward deploy engineering.
It's just because the prosumer
adoption is not quite there.
Enterprise, a lot of them don't know
how to adopt these technology
and build effective product around it.
So therefore, a lot of
startups come in to actually do
a lot of these forward deploy methods
to actually go really deep
into the organization.
So, this is the problem,
I think that everyone is
trying to solve right now,
all the big cloud vendors as well.
Because I think that's the
final piece of the question.
Because I think ROI,
we can narrow it down.
The consumer side, you can
also narrow it down as well
with the forward deployment model.
But the prosumer, real, real challenging.
I think, but the prosumer
adoption would gradually improve
as technology become better,
and then we need to shift,
create more product layers
on top of these foundational models.
So, actually much more easier
to learn and interact with.
- That's super helpful.
I think that gap in closing
that last 20%, right,
is so fundamental.
How do you think about
what to prioritize first
when you're trying to
close that gap, right?
We definitely hear companies
talking about speed, right,
is really important.
So, there's not just a
very uncomfortable lag
in the conversation,
where it's just to your point,
a very inhuman interaction.
But then at the same time,
there's probably issues
like accuracy, right,
at the end of the day.
Talk to us a little bit
about from an engineering perspective
how you think about prioritization
of closing that gap.
- Yeah, it's a very, very good question.
It's a tough problem.
I think one company alone
cannot solve those problems.
That's why we partner with Nvidia
to actually solve some of the problems.
Like latency, we shouldn't worry about it.
Because Nvidia should have the best GPUs
and best software knows
how to run on those GPUs
to solve that problem for us.
So, that is just something
that we decided to take that,
that on partnering with Nvidia.
And I think accuracy is
about collecting the data
and then continuously improve your model.
So, I think that continuous improvement
actually matters a lot.
But there's also fundamentally
the model that you are using,
does it actually,
is it that sufficient for your problems?
One very interesting use case
is we have this outbound call,
where the human picking up a call.
When the agent make a
outbound, human pick up a call,
accuracy was perfect.
But then once there's a
robotic IVR pick up the call,
the accuracy just complete poor.
It's just because the model didn't see
this kind of data before.
So therefore, I think that
the approach we're taking
is that we decided which
areas we wanted to partner
so that we remove those
out of our priorities.
Then the second piece would be,
well building a very
flexible infrastructure.
Because the good thing is
that everyone is trying
to solve a problem for you,
because AI is making so much
elements in the past year,
so many companies working, okay.
So, you kind of have to need
to have a flexible infrastructure ready
to take on all these new technology.
So, I think the second way
we are doing is just building
a very flexible platform
so you can integrate it
with the latest technology
when they are available.
- Got it.
Flexibility and option value.
'Cause yeah, you said it so well.
The ecosystem is just proliferating
at a very incredible rate, right?
- Correct, yeah.
- And what you think
is not available today,
sometimes it's a matter
of just weeks, right?
It's no longer months, given
how fast the market's going.
- And to really riff off that
for a minute, if it's okay.
- Please.
- A non-engineering perspective off of it.
Which is fine.
There's nothing wrong,
it's a good perspective.
The way we think about it is,
there's a set of basics, right?
A latency of four seconds
is not gonna be acceptable.
So, there's a set of basics,
there's a set of accuracy
you've gotta at least be at.
There's a set of infrastructure
things that have to be true,
and cost structures that have to be true.
Those are minimum hurdles.
Which one am I gonna prioritize?
They all need to be true.
Right?
All three of these things,
there's a minimum level,
and you need to decide
what those minimum levels
of things to be true.
There's no prioritization there,
they all just have to be true.
But you need to understand what that is
and decide what that is
for your use case, right?
Once I have that, then it starts to be,
and this is where maybe
I'm just the product
of 20 years at Disney, and
my experience is there,
then it starts to be about the experience.
To your point.
Because it doesn't
matter how accurate it is
if it sucks, right?
So, do I work, do I give you
two more points of accuracy
or five more points of accuracy?
But it's a really bad experience
'cause the latency sucks,
or the voice doesn't sound
right, or is off-putting.
So, I'm a firm believer
that once you hit the minimum levels,
your number one priority
needs to be that experience
for that use case.
Because, Shawn said we've been there.
The reason why I think people
are still where they are
is because they're so used to,
how quickly can I hit zero?
Because I'm used to the,
like the NLPs, they're like,
they're really bad,
they can only answer the
questions they've been trained on,
which is 20 questions in a chat bot.
And they can't do anything
but those five things.
And it's just frustrating,
just let me talk to a person.
So we're, in my world,
we're still stuck in sort
of apple-Newton world.
Of, my experience is this.
We're really moving toward iPhone world,
but nobody's tried it enough yet
and we're not all there yet.
Unless we get enough people in that space,
we're gonna have our
hard time moving people
along that continuum.
Just my perspective.
- Oh, that's super helpful, Cam.
'Cause I think in many ways
what I'm hearing from you
is customer trust at the end
of the day is everything.
And so, there's a minimum set
of sacred sort of standards,
right, for your brand to make sure,
in order to play this game
it's important to provide.
Awesome.
Prem, anything you wanna add?
- Yeah, I agree with what
Cameron said on that.
Just to get an intro perspective on that.
Especially when it comes to models,
you always look at models in silos,
like how are the models
perform in terms of accuracy,
or precision, whatever.
But you also have
to look at it from an
end-to-end perspective as well.
And you need to look at how
the whole customer experience,
it's like you put the model in,
okay, it's got good performance.
But at the end of the day,
when you go through a
whole customer journey
that's more really help the user achieve
what they want to achieve,
and the performance and the
experience they get out of it.
That's really important to how it's like
when you're using like
agents like voice AI.
- I mean, in your world...
The whole point is,
in medical world I talk to the client,
and I gotta remember,
and I'm spending over half my
time actually just charting
versus dealing with care.
And that's frustrating
if you're the medical.
So, you're trying to deal
with the fact that I can take
the thing about your job
you really don't like
that's necessary,
move it up in that experience chain,
and I can spend more time.
But if at the end of the day
I go and go back and check,
and all those things are inaccurate,
I actually made it worse.
- Exactly.
- I would've been better
off just to do it myself
the first time.
- That would just double your time, right?
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
And also, like doctors
didn't spend five years
in medical school just to
sit in front of the computer
and take notes.
They want to be a doctor.
And Heidi really does that really well.
And voice AI is like,
it really enables that,
to take it from a point
where the doctors don't have
to worry too much about
what they're saying.
But if the model is not
really that accurate,
then that actually means that it creates,
well it pulls down the
line but not so really bad.
And the coding and billing everything,
you can't really trust that anymore.
- Yeah.
Thanks gentlemen.
Let's switch to another
topic here on scale,
related to scaling, which is,
we're here at AWS re:Invent.
I think Amazon in many ways
deserves so much credit
'cause they pioneered
far field communication
with Alexa and Echo,
and really took the
industry in a new direction.
When it comes to voice AI,
how are you seeing AI manage
kind of nuances specific
to voice?
Whether that's like a regional accent,
whether that's noise in the background,
you all kind of have a
unique perspective given
from where you sit.
So, would love to hear how
you're seeing AI manage
some of that auditory
complexity and nuance.
- Yeah, I think from a very
technical point of view,
and then after seeing
several technology iterations
in the past is that you
have a lot of these local
or regional issues really.
Like accent of a particular kind,
or like particular kind
of understanding problems.
I remember in the past
nuance used to focus a lot
on healthcare space.
It's basically tailored vocabulary
for those use cases, right?
But then if you see the
technology evolution,
especially in machine learning world,
is becoming a more, from a
cascading system to be a more,
like completely connected
large newer networks.
I think that's just,
I think when I was thinking
about where to invest in
and then where to solve
the problem is like,
it's very important to remember
that the technology will
eventually move there.
And I think LLM I
remember when previously,
when we did chat bots,
it's about intent language understanding,
and you have some decision makings,
and you writing some template text,
and then it's a cascading pipeline.
But then now, is that
complete end-to-end training.
We have now the speech
to speech models as well.
It's try to join all
these modalities together.
To be frank, I don't think the
technology quite there yet,
but I do actually think that
this is definitely the future.
And so, if the technology
is going to evolve that way,
and you do actually have a
problem to solve right now,
then you just need to solve the problem.
If you can solve it in a nice way, great.
But if that problem is only,
open AI can solve the problem,
then that then solve the problem, right?
You can patch around
that problem right now
so that you can have a production system
that's kind of ready to use.
Because what you want now
is what you want to ship the product now
rather than ship the
product several years later
once the technology become there.
But you always need to keep in mind
that technology would eventually catch up.
So, how do you build up
infrastructure or architecture
that factor that in in the future,
I think it's quite important.
And I think this is quite...
Because internally six months ago,
we have this review of,
oh, do we continue to cut,
invest in cascading systems
or end-to-end systems?
And then we did a lot of
testing within ourselves
and also with the clients.
The conclusion is always like,
in the future an end-to-end
system will be the future.
- I mean, the technology
will continue to change.
I'd say the first thing is,
we should continue to
reset the expectation
of what the standard is.
And what I mean by that is,
every time we try to do something with AI,
we could talk about it.
Like when my head of AI's
in the back of the room
with forecasting, and they're like,
"Well is it a hundred percent?"
Like, well you're not a hundred percent.
Right?
- [Andrew] We're close, close.
- So, standards should be,
like, what is the standard?
And right now when we talk about accents,
has anybody in this room
ever had a conversation
with someone who had an accent
that was different from theirs
and you had to ask them
to repeat something?
Of course you have.
Right, of course you have.
So, the expectation isn't that
the AI will perfectly hear
every accent perfectly and respond to it.
The standards should be,
how does it adjust when it doesn't, right?
With that technology,
and where do we tune it to specific places
to make sure those things that we know.
And we have a joke right now.
One of our heads on the product side is,
went to Oxford and he's got
a very proper English accent.
Our current voice ordering
hates Gean's accent.
(panelists laugh)
It's hilarious.
Everybody else will test it.
It'll get 80, 90%.
Gean tested, it'll get to 50%.
He'll yell at the thing, he'll call me.
"This thing is shit.
I can't believe we're doing this thing."
And it's Gean's accent.
So, we could tune it to him.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- But unfortunately across the US,
that's not the standardized
accent that we're going after.
Now, when we release in
the UK, we probably will.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- But so.
And then the other is the voice canceling,
the noise canceling, all
that stuff will come along.
But I think setting the expectation right
is the first thing.
That people tend to set it the wrong way.
- [Andrew] Yeah.
Yeah, and then fine
tuning it for bullocks.
- Yeah, well the thing is that
I completely agree with you.
And then we are expecting
AI to be better than human,
which isn't fair because
there's a lot of news.
People go on the news and
then say that AGI is arriving.
The reality is,
I think the expectation
has been set way too high.
So yeah.
- Prem, any thoughts on
kind of how you think
about your decisions of cascading
versus composable, right?
This whole idea is really,
whether it's the business
or the technical side
of how do you think about the architecture
in a world where you know
where the world's going.
How do you think about it technically?
- Yeah, I think Shawn kind of mentioned it
by making the platform flexible.
And especially where you
are, when you're a startup,
you're really experimenting
different things.
You don't know what works,
and you want to make sure
that you really stay in a way
you can quickly adapt to change.
So, if you're using a
composable architecture,
it really helps with
enabling something like that.
So, when using composable architecture,
you're just making the
components really modular.
So, it makes it like,
it's like hot swappable.
You can, like for example,
if you look at Heidi,
there's transcription,
there's a non generation part,
there's billing.
And the way we set it up,
we make sure that each
part is really replaceable
with something new.
And given the way things are, even if,
like for example,
if you're using like an
agent driven architecture,
where you have LLMs
interacting with each other,
there's a lot of models
coming around all the time,
there's different kind of tools
coming around all the time.
So, you need to make
sure that your platform
is flexible enough to
trade and change based on
what was coming out.
So, that you know how
the flexibility change.
But on the other hand,
cascading is really efficient
when you're working in a
place where you know exactly
what the system needs to be like.
Once you ironed out how you
want a certain feature to be,
then you can just, like, okay,
this is the maximum we're gonna go.
Okay, then at that point
we fix certain things
and then we set it up.
Okay, one thing after the other,
this is how the flow goes.
And also, really helpful
when you want monitoring
and different things enabled,
and also it will be very
fault current as well.
'Cause one of the downside of
having a flexible architecture
is that it's really hard to know,
when things go wrong you have to,
it makes it a bit hard to debug when you,
there's a lot of moving parts around.
But at the same time it's
a price you have to pay
to stay flexible.
- Yeah.
Look, I think it's a great question,
it's one we constantly ask ourselves.
I've been married to the
same woman for 35 years,
I have no fear of commitment.
I'm not worried about that.
What I am worried about is I don't have,
I've never had those same kind of feelings
for any kind of technology
vendor I've ever met, right?
So, finding that balance is key.
And is what we just said.
There's pieces of it I'm
just gonna need to commit to.
'Cause I don't know.
And that commitment will
create a set of stability,
recurrence, trainability on
my team, and an expectation.
Realizing that I may be behind,
and then there's pieces that I know
we need to be composable on.
And so, we're constantly
reinventing the architecture.
By the way, we just had this conversation.
It's not just on the technology side.
We had a whole conversation last night
about our entire data infrastructure.
And our current set of schemas
and the way we've done it,
like, you know what,
it was really great for a set of reporting
and analytics that we were doing.
It's not set up the way
we need it to be set up
to feed some of our upcoming LLMs
and some of the more generative AI.
So, how do we do that, right?
And how do we flex it?
I don't regret the money
we put in five years ago
to get a great star schema
to do what we needed to do.
Right, that's fine, right?
And I have no problem with the fact
that we need to now reinvest and adjust.
But there are certain elements of models,
for example, we were talking
about changing out modeling.
Some of them will get
better, some of them won't.
And so how, where I know the
composability will be key,
how do I architect around that
to balance the trade offs?
- Super insightful.
Given we have a kind of
different perspective,
both on the enterprise
side as the ISV side,
sort of different stages of maturity
in terms of your organizations.
Talk to us about how do
you or your customers make
that decision of what to build
when it comes to voice
in-house versus partnering.
- I guess I'm the one
non vendor on the stage.
(panelists laugh)
So, but you guys, I'd
love your perspective.
I can say for us,
we have a sort of a standardized filter
that starts with IP.
Is there something we know
that we wanna keep to us,
or something we that
somebody else doesn't.
Or is there something they
know that we don't have,
and that would be a huge speed to market?
I'll use a non-voice example on...
We use a third party to
do email customization.
And when we looked at the
way they were doing it,
Rocky and I sat aside,
like, yeah, we could probably
figure this out over time.
It probably takes us about 18
months of research to do it.
And at that time the
opportunity cost is gone.
Let's just sign the
contract and go, right?
'Cause the IP was already there,
and then it's about cost
and speed to market, right?
And then the third thing
for us is integration.
Not only are we the world's
largest restaurant company,
but we are quickly becoming
the world's largest restaurant
technology company with Bite.
And so, there is a lock in of integration
with our technology
that we also care about,
is that we've added as a fourth filter.
- That's such a critical point.
I think so many times in paradigm shifts,
people race for speed, right?
And speed is important in a market.
It's important to learn,
and rapidly learn.
But there's always this
fundamental strategy question
that we see often at the C level around,
who owns this intelligence, right?
And what is truly sacred.
And that's a really thoughtful decision,
and an important one to kind of navigate
your approach on.
- Well, and that's like,
more than ever we'll go to the voice.
No matter what, we own those recordings
and we own that data.
No matter what.
And all the customer data,
no matter what, we own it.
We even own it with our third
party aggregators, by the way.
So, we're serious about that.
And that's a key for us.
- Yeah, I think with Bite,
especially in the investments
that Yum! has made,
I think it was a billion to date, right?
And in terms of how much
they've put in, the talent,
you can see that it's not
just sort of a vocal strategy,
right?
There's real technology
with real talent there.
Shawn, you were gonna say something?
- Yeah, I think in this...
So, voice agent itself has
a really complicated modules
and technical stack.
In order to actually
make voice agent works,
not just for one use cases
but for many, many use cases,
because that's the
industry we are in, right?
Because it's not just about
building a retail use case
or financial services.
We have to actually sell
into a lot of different customers as well.
So, in order to do that,
the things that we have to
build is actually a lot.
And so then, deciding what
you do and what you not to do
become very important.
And I think this is always
the biggest question for startup's.
It's like, what's your core value add,
and what do you focus on predominantly
because you have limited resources.
To us, it's always about delivering
that voice agent X B2B appearances.
And we are focusing on
building up the application
for the end customers,
either for the consumer or enterprises.
So with that in mind,
we have been focusing on
building the product layer
to make it easily configurable
for different industries
and different purpose.
Different use cases that
they're looking for.
So, that has been quite fundamental.
We also find ourself,
because our goal is to deliver
the best user X B2B appearance
as much as possible.
Because we see that from our
conversation with customers,
that's the reason they come
to PolyAI at the first place.
So, we'll have to invest in
areas we think that is needed.
That's the reason we started
to invest our own speech
recognition model.
Because we previously found that
some of the off the shelf
speech APIs works perfectly.
But for some use cases,
you started to see there
are limitations there.
And without controlling that
particular technical stack,
you kind of limited by what you can do
to deliver that best X B2B appearance.
And in the old days
speech recognition model
is such a big problem because there's,
it's not an end-to-end model yet.
It's like you have this
language model, acoustic model,
and then you have a vocabulary,
all these things that need to
be, again a pipeline system.
So, we have always
hesitate to invest in that
until we realized, oh Nvidia
started to do their own models
and streamline this entire pipeline.
And it was just, okay well
let's take that base model,
and then we train our own model up,
train our own data and tailor to it.
And it solve so many of the problems
that we will not be able
to solve previously.
So, I guess what I'm trying
to use these examples to say
is that only model is not
a goal, is not a strategy,
but be able to deliver a
best user X B2B appearance
for our clients is the goal.
But then the goal takes
us to actually invest
in this particular area.
So, I think you always need to
find what is your north star
that you are trying to achieve.
Say no to majority of things.
And then realize,
oh, this is one thing or
two I have to invest in.
- [Andrew] Great.
Prem, anything you wanna add to this?
- I think Cameron and Shawn,
they covered pretty much
everything I wanted to say.
But it's more about just
how what your business is,
how much you want to outsource.
It's like when you're starting off
you want to make sure you get
your product to users first.
And what's the best way to do it.
If it's something that's
business critical,
you wanna make sure that you
dealt with that in house.
But if it's something
that can be outsourced,
if there's like an API provider
you can use, you use that.
And it's also, you have limited resources.
So you prioritize.
Like, where do I invest my resources now?
Is it something that I can
figure out down the line?
Okay cool, I'll just use a
third party, get it over with,
and then figure it out later.
But if it's really
critical to the business.
Okay, I'm gonna send my resource
to research and development
and get it up and running,
and disturb my users.
It's just about how you
prioritize your resources.
- Great.
So, moving on in terms of
enabling this technology.
Clearly the ecosystem matters.
There's so many different
players that are critical.
What do you think are the
most critical ingredients
for a business leader to look for
when they are trying to
decide on a voice AI platform?
- I'll say from our perspective it's...
We've already hit on a couple of them.
For us, it's...
Personally, is it somebody
we wanna work with?
You say that, but we've all had people
that we've worked with,
with vendors in the past,
and like, yeah, I just
would prefer never to work
with those people ever again.
And then there's people you worked with
you still have relationships with today
because they were just really
good and easy to work with.
You can come to win-wins.
And so for us,
that's just the number one thing we meet.
So, is this somebody that's
on the same page as us?
Do they wanna work with?
Then it starts to be about
the technology piece of it.
And sometimes I don't want
the most cutting edge.
Sometimes I want the one
that's gonna integrate
with my technology the easiest,
people that are gonna work
with my people the easiest.
And then there's a minimum set.
And then it becomes to that lock, right,
where we talk about commitment, right?
How composable is the
system, can you speak,
can you work with my other things?
Do I have to do the integrations?
'Cause we die on the integration
hill all the time, right?
We all see it.
We die on the integration hill.
So, like what's already there?
What am I gonna pay for?
What are you gonna pay for?
And then that composability, right?
And the firm belief that if
you have to lock me in so hard
that I have no optionality,
then you obviously don't believe
that strongly in your product.
That's my theory.
If you believe in your product,
you're not gonna have
to lock me in that hard,
because it's going to be so good
I'm never gonna want to leave it.
And you need to put the
faith in the product.
- That's a great point.
And it kind of segues nicely
in terms of this decision
that a lot of businesses
have to come up with.
Of when to use open source,
versus when to use a
more proprietary model?
Curious if gentlemen can talk a little bit
about that decision
framework for your company
or in customers that you've seen.
- Yeah, I would say from my perspective,
always start with the
easiest to start with.
Because you wanted to first prove
that this technology brings you ROI,
you wanted to prove that this technology
is actually helping your business
in the way that you want them to.
And so, I think that invest
too early on in the open source
is probably not the right strategy.
I think that you should give
it a try on the latest close.
Those APIs, the easiest
you can integrate it to,
try to build something with your workflow.
And if that works well and
you prove that there' a ROI,
and you realize it's not sufficient,
and then open source can actually solve
that problem for you, then
you should go that way.
That's how we did with our ASR models.
That's how we did with our
in-house ALM one models as well.
It's only when ChatGPT came along,
we just throw all the APIs to them.
Just try to build, iterate
on the product faster.
And then over time you realize,
oh there are problems with
this, and that and that.
And you don't want it to be
bounded by a particular roadmap
of a company, then that's
where I think that investing
in your own model would
actually make sense.
But I think the,
it needs to be a very
deliberate calculation
because you don't want it
to invest in technology
that you don't actually need eventually.
- Yeah, it's the same.
I'm a firm believer in open source.
I believe most of the things
that's built on technology or software,
it's all built on open source.
But having said that, I
agree with what Shawn said.
When you're entering a market,
you're trying to prove a concept.
And your resources are limited,
you wanna invest too much in open source.
And also the quality of
the open source models
is not up to par with the
foundation models yet.
I feel like it might take
maybe two or three iterations
to open source models to catch up to
all the foundation wants.
But you want to prove a concept,
so the fastest way is you use
one of the APIs for wrappers,
and make sure that you get,
okay, I've got a product that works
and I've got enough customer bases,
I've got enough resources.
And now, okay it's time to
invest into an open source,
or invest in my own
department without R and D.
And once you get that point and you can,
there's a lot you can do,
you have the flexibility.
'Cause a lot of the reasons
why people move away
from foundation or frontier models
from different providers and calls,
is everything's behind an API.
You don't know what's happening there,
everything's abstracted away from an API.
But you get to a point
where you want to own
a lot of those components,
like different things,
how you wanna do it.
And then once you attain a certain point,
you'll be tired of just
having to call random API.
To get one thing done,
you might have to call
three different APIs.
And you can just get
some open source models, hosting yourself,
and do a much better job than they can do.
'Cause what these foundation models,
what they do is they give
you a generic use case.
But based on your business needs,
it might be a bit different.
And they may not be flexible enough
to integrate that into your future.
And then you get to a point where,
okay, this is where I start
investing in my own R and D
and get my product to a place
where these services can
no longer support me.
- [Andrew] All right.
Cam, you mentioned earlier
a lot of the business
outcomes you're seeing
and the measurement of it.
I'm curious if other folks
on the panel can talk
a little bit about
tangible business outcomes,
and potentially to the extent
you can share business measurement
that you're seeing outta
your customers, right?
In terms of impacts to their business.
When it comes to
integrating voice obviously.
- I'm sorry, could you repeat that again?
Sorry.
- [Andrew] Yeah, just in terms
of are there any examples
of business outcomes
from integrating voice
that you're seeing in health, for example?
- Yeah.
- [Andrew] And similarly, Shawn,
you serve multiple industries.
Talk to us a little bit about that.
- In terms of health.
One thing we've noticed,
that clinicians are
very hesitant to change.
Like when you're trying to
introduce a new software,
they'll rather, even if it's very helpful,
they'd rather stick to whatever
they have up and running
'cause they're not that tech savvy
like an engineers would be.
And they have something
that's set out and that works,
and they don't wanna break it.
And what we've observed,
that when you have a software
that's built on top of voice,
it kind of makes it easier
for clinicians to interact
with your product.
They don't even have to know it's there.
It's just something that's
running in the background.
No one's gonna notice it's there.
You only know it when
you interact with it.
You start recording and
then you stop recording.
That's pretty much all you have to do.
And also the downstream tasks as well.
You can automate a lot of that as well,
like the billing and medical coding,
and integrations and things like that.
With the beauty of Heidi
is it has integration
with a lot of EHRs,
so that notes are not just sitting there
in a standalone software or something.
Once you've done a
consultation, we have the notes,
and then it moves into an EHR.
It's just there ready to go.
And you can also take care
of your downstream workflows as well.
And all of that is being
made possible with voice AI.
So, I feel like there's a
big wave of change coming,
and voice AI is gonna
play a big role in it.
- [Andrew] Shawn, anything in terms
of your cross industry
view around business?
- Yeah, so I think it's
very interesting that,
because when we started working
on the contact center industry overall
we thought that cost is the primary thing.
And then a lot of people
thought that we're just trying
to use AI to replace humans.
The reality is that once
you deploy these voice agent
in various different industries,
you kind of starting to realize
that different industries
actually care about different things,
and they are seeking
ROIs in different ways.
So, the retail example I just mentioned
is about smooth that demand curve.
So then they can actually,
they don't have to over
hire that many people
in training lab and
then let them go later.
So, that workforce management
is a very important piece to them.
That's for retail, because
they have seasonality.
For restaurants we work
with, they actually,
we do a lot of reservations
and bookings for them.
And it's actually very
funny that on average,
restaurants actually missing
about 20% to 30% of their calls
because just about the
kind of things involved
that is happening inside of a restaurant.
People running around,
especially at the peak hours,
to actually pick up the call.
And then sometimes if there's
availability one hour later
they don't even negotiate
that availability.
So, the covers will not fail for example.
So, and then we just
found that restaurants,
we usually find that they
are, for large enterprises,
they found a value in,
not just about the company and the law,
but also be able to pick up
some of those revenues as well.
So, I think we are helping them
to increase with maybe a 4%,
5% of the revenue once
deployed the voice agent.
Which is the kind of
ROI we would not expect
to begin with, right?
So, I think there are a lot
of these different aspects,
and think different
industries are different,
so you kind of have to deploy something
and learn with the
clients on that journey.
- The retail examples hits home obviously.
Just because to your point,
the expectation versus the
discovery was quite opposite.
Right?
And in retail, customer service typically,
especially as things move more digitally,
you have last mile shipping costs.
- Yes.
- And then when you can
serve a customer well,
you avoid the return additional
last mile shipping cost,
right?
That recovery cost.
And so, when you serve
your customer as well,
it can improve not only
customer life and value,
but the actual order economics.
- Correct, yeah.
Exactly.
- It's interesting that,
'cause you imagine a world
where right now you call
and you're put on hold
to deal with something
because the IBR can't handle
what you need it to do.
And you have a choice, stay
on hold for 45 minutes,
or give me your number
and I'll call you back.
I think we're moving
toward a third option,
which is, or just talk
to the virtual agent.
- Oh yeah.
- Which most of us are like,
well if they can handle it,
why wouldn't I of those three options?
And then what you see is
in the restaurant use case
on the reservations,
and I've talked a lot
of folks in our space,
we don't do that obviously,
but the ones that do,
that idea of nobody's ever on hold.
Somebody's always gonna pick up the phone,
and so what that does to
their top line demand driver.
It was there, but they were in,
revenue management world
we called it an enable.
You lost the business,
you had no idea you lost the business
because of availability or
nobody picked up the call, right?
And so as that goes away,
I think it's gonna be an
interesting, as in your world,
as that business case continues to flow.
Because it's a very,
I'm booking a reservation for this time.
Right, so it's very clean,
it's very contained,
and yet somebody can, I'd
rather do that than not.
- Yeah.
That's a great example, Cam.
And we see that in voice
adjacent with vision.
Like in retail, often retail
companies will come in
and they'll start using
computer vision to detect
and automate and smooth out
self-checkout at a store.
And as they can use more
accelerated computing,
they realize that there's
a lot more workloads
that they can actually
run on that same GPU.
And so, the detection of the use case
they didn't even realize they had, right.
It's suddenly they're
looking at movement patterns
of their customers,
and how long they're waiting
in line not just at checkout,
but at the deli.
A great example is Kohl's
in Australia realized
if customers wait more
than 45 seconds at a deli,
then they're gonna leave that line.
And so, now they can actually
perceive it, understand it,
alert the customers, and its
incremental revenue, right.
- And we're talking voice,
but Lowe's isn't here,
but we all know those folks.
And the way they're
starting to do it the old,
I don't see it in your bag, right?
The way that's just a terrible experience.
Now, the computer vision's watching
what comes out of the cart
and goes into the bag,
and say, "Hey, I think you
may have missed something."
Like, "I counted 14 items."
It's less intrusive, right?
And it's a lot smoother.
But what it's doing for them on shrinkage
is really interesting.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's all about
reducing the friction
and making it really convenient.
Alright, let's kind of move to kind
of the final group of questions here,
which is really about guidance.
You all are unique leaders in
your respective industries.
For an organization that's
just starting in voice AI,
what's the top lesson or lessons
that you wish you had known
from the outset?
- Yeah, I'd say that if I was gonna give
anybody advice on this,
and this is just not just
voice, this is anything.
One of the hardest things to
do is know when to let go.
And we talk about failing fast,
and it's like, no, no, no,
you need to fail cheap.
Because you fail fast and
expensive, that's still not good.
You need to fail cheap.
But one of the things, and we,
if I go back the last five years at Yum!,
just used that as an example,
I can name six things right now
that we have now stopped doing.
Right, we tried it.
We tried it, it didn't work.
And every one of those
projects had somebody
who was really passionate about it,
that really believed in it.
And if we just gave it another try,
we could make it work, right?
And one of the hardest
things to do is saying,
you know what, this isn't working.
It's not worth the effort right now.
Or maybe the time's not right,
maybe the technology's not there.
and I know we've invested in it.
But I've literally met
people that will let a spouse
or a relative go before they'll
let that project go, right?
And so, getting that...
Learning and putting the rules in place,
and the stage gates in place upfront.
Put it up front and say,
hey, these are what the stage gates are.
Here's what success are.
When will we call it?
What needs to be true by this point,
or we're just gonna put it
away for the time being?
And there are projects
that we let go on too long
because we didn't do that up front.
And not only was it a net cost,
there were opportunity cost,
things we should have been working on,
we could have been working
on that we weren't.
And that's the, I think is people come in,
the best advice I give 'em right now.
Let's set that up front.
Every project, let's set the stage gates
and understand it now,
so when the time comes
we're gonna call it, right?
We're gonna put a motion aside,
we've already made the agreement.
And unless something's changed,
that's what we're gonna do.
- Yeah, I totally agree with that.
Because I think, what I want
to add on top of that is,
because I think voice agent,
despite that there's a lot,
we have made a lot of progress there,
technically the technology
still has a lot to go,
to be honest.
I think if you done it right,
it's completely possible
to actually solve your problem already.
But it's very likely that you are going
to end up lots of resource,
spending a lot of resources
and not going anywhere.
So because of that,
setting up those milestones
are very important.
Also, finding a partner that are willing
to actually go really deep
and really far with you
is very important as well.
That's why there's a lots of startups
out there doing FDE models.
We are also doing that as well.
And if they are doing the
FDE models, try them out,
let them build things for you.
Maybe it's a cheaper way for you
to actually speed the pyramid.
And there's a lot of competition now
in voice agent companies.
So, you can negotiate
the deals, good for you.
And then just give it a try.
And I think that is probably a way
that you should go as well,
rather than also thinking about putting
all these big technology boxes together,
because that's actually a
lot you have to do as well.
So, find a cheaper way to X B2B human,
and finding a partner that you can lean on
and trust to work on, I
think would be my suggestion.
- My advice is from an
engineering perspective.
And I think it's not just for voice AI,
it's for any project that
you start working on.
It's always good to start small.
Like you can think of building
something piece by piece,
like putting the Lego pieces together,
making sure that you
stay flexible on the way.
You have a feature or a
product you wanna build,
you wanna try and have a
proof of concept built.
And you start really small,
you use whatever resources you have.
APIs, open source,
whatever you think is
best you start with that.
And then you, once you
get some validation,
you start building on top of it.
You have some components there.
Okay, earlier I used a
third party or a vendor,
maybe the latency's not that great.
You swap it out, you put
a different piece on.
And then brick by brick, piece by piece,
you start building it,
and then you get to a place where you are,
the product is very flexible.
'Cause like Shawn said,
the technology that we have these days,
every day there's a new model coming out.
And if you want to make sure,
if you wanna stay relevant
and make sure the model
is performing at it's best,
you wanna make sure
that you're leaning in,
you're making sure that you're
using the best out there.
And having them build piece by piece,
really make sure that you stay flexible
and you can adapt to change
as quickly as possible.
- Great.
Shawn, Cam, Prem, thank you so much
for spending time with us today.
We hope you all found
today's session interesting,
and learned something new as
you go on your voice journey.
And Amazon obviously, thank
you for having us here today.